It can't be
helped. Don't tell the president. Mr. Lambo's super deduction. We
finally understand Kamui's true identity. Movement, Power, Who is
Kamui? God is
using Nikolai as a pawn. In other words, he is a
person with such power and charisma.
And sin.  Kamui is the person who made a huge profit from a series of terrorist attacks
because he chose the detective agency as the organization to carry out the crime, so he has ties to the people
involved, or is related to the deceased.There
is no evidence, but Tsujiyoshi is Tokyo.I will
live first.  I guess it's a little lonely to find out,
right? Is this the way you want to live?
What can I do? He noticed what I realized. I have
a few seconds to spare. Lambo-san,
my reference point
is to face the same direction as the president. That's why
I, too,  It was
my mistake,
not yours.That was my
father's mystery novel that Lambo carried as a daily refuge.Another divine
abilityis the
performance of the weapon he possesses.